estos obreros van a construir almacenes
sin usar los materiales típicos para
construcción en su lugar utilizarán
droga decomisada al narcotráfico
se le llama técnica del encapsulamiento
y consiste en pulverizar los
estupefacientes con químicos y concreto
para moldear capas de suelos el teniente
Paulo está a cargo de vigilar el proceso
lo que nosotros generamos es una
respectiva orden de servicio que nos
permite evaluar el riesgo para evaluar
este riesgo nos manejamos en varios
indicadores ya sea la cantidad de
personas que van a asistir al proceso de
destrucción la cantidad de sustancia y
especialmente la distancia de donde sale
la sustancia
hoy llegan tres toneladas de cocaína
custodiada por la policía para el
procedimiento de pulverización Ecuador
Es el tercer país del mundo por debajo
de Colombia y los Estados Unidos de
comenzar sustancias ilegales según el
informe de las Naciones Unidas del año
2022 en ese mismo periodo la policía
nacional ecuatoriana retuvo 200 un
toneladas que ahora tienen nueva
utilidad cuando esta piscina o esta
celda de seguridad sea completamente
llena va a ser puesta una capa extra de
concreto y como lo vemos posteriormente
servirá para bodegas de la propia
empresa no para otro menester 400
toneladas de cocaína Fueron encapsuladas
por Ecuador desde el año 2018 hasta la
fecha una tendencia que continúa al alza
según asegura este agente policial que
ha pedido proteger su identidad un 80%
Ya que en relación a los años anteriores
Pues hay
hay siquiera hay unas 20-30 toneladas
más de relación a los años anteriores
Ecuador aspiratorgar licencias
ambientales a personal especializado
para proyectar el uso de Esta técnica en
el tiempo el gobierno ha tenido que
crear esta iniciativa porque la
incautación de drogas en el país ha
desbordado la capacidad del estado en
cuanto a incineración traslado y
seguridad